after the long-running hit How I Met
Your Mother left the lineup CBS planned
a spin-off and even filmed a pilot but
pulled the plug before the show reached
the airwaves here's a look at the
reasons we still haven't seen How I Met
Your dad though series creators Carter
Bays and Craig Thomas along with writer
Emilie Spivey shot a pilot for How I Met
Your dad CBS kicked it back for reshoots
this didn't sit well with the trio who
said that they wouldn't reshoot the
pilots unless CBS gave a commitment to
take it to series CBS pushed back
refusing to give the show a series order
without seeing the reshoots first much
to the dismay of How I Met Your Mother
superfans CBS officially passed on the
spinoff in May 2014
citing certain creative elements as the
reason why when the pilot script for How
I Met Your dad was released by the
website TV writing in April 2016 the
mystery of why the show was never picked
up became a bit more clear for one the
dialogue was awkward and stilted
featuring lines like breakups are like
kidnappings the first 48 hours are
crucial you got to blow up the bridge
behind you and the only way to do it is
by doing it with a dude and you're a
slob Sally dishes everywhere dirty
laundry and you always leave cabinet
doors open for a while I thought we had
a poltergeist
of course dialogue is almost always
worse when you're reading it off the
cold pages of a script but these lines
felt deeply unnatural and fans of How I
Met Your Mother had come to expect a
certain level of quality
that's the passes for comedy these days
whoa falling back to my chair I'm really
falling back in my chair The awkward
problematic script might have been what
led to the exit a Broadway actress
krysta Rodriguez who was originally set
to play the best friend to Greta Gerwig
lead character however Rodriguez
reportedly left the show just days
before production was set to begin
though her departure was never fully
explained the talented actress who
originated the role of Wednesday Addams
and The Addams Family musical
could have been a big hit for the series
she was replaced by tiya Sircar best
known for her roles in a good place and
Alex ink when Greta Gerwig was cast in
how I met your dad's leading role many
people wondered how the actresses
signature quirky humor would fit into
the sitcom medium and
fans were unsure if the indie film star
had enough recognition to carry such an
anticipated series while CBS was
reportedly happy with Gurewitz portrayal
of the lead they weren't as pleased with
two of the other members of the
five-person cast while declining to name
names anonymous sources claimed two of
the main characters were a sore spot for
network executives who felt they simply
didn't pop alongside girl Rekha and
those CBS liked Gerwig the network may
not have been totally satisfied with the
lead character as a whole Sally who is
described as a female Peter Pan who has
never grown up and has no idea of where
she's going with her life might have
been too much of a mess for audiences to
fall in love with which reportedly was a
point of concern for CBS oh honey
networks take a number of things into
consideration when deciding whether or
not to order a series and while quality
is a big part of it it's not the only
thing that matters now I met your dad
like how i met your mother was a 20th
Century Fox property meeting that Fox
would make money from an eventual
potentially lucrative syndication deal
if this series took off not CBS well
this wouldn't be the only thing stopping
the network from ordering the pilots it
would definitely put it at a
disadvantage against other comedy pilots
that the network was developing in-house
like Matthew Perry's doomed remake of
The Odd Couple How I Met Your Mother was
successful partly because it was
different from every other sitcom on TV
the series had an original and
refreshing format which made the pilot
stand out instantly however How I Met
Your dad didn't benefit from this
originality the original format was
already stale after nine seasons and the
How I Met Your dad pilot did nothing to
revamp it just as How I Met Your Mother
started with Ted talking to his teenage
kids about the first time he met their
aunt Robin the How I Met Your dad pilot
saw Sally recounting to her kids the
first time she met Frank who was assumed
to be the titular dad before finally
ending with a big reveal that he's
actually uncle Frank while that worked
for the original series the revamp
needed to do something bigger and bolder
in order to set itself apart I kept this
story short and to the point and you
guys still missed it fans lamenting the
loss of another chapter in the how I Met
Your Mother saga got an unexpected
surprise in December of 2016
it was reported that the spin-off now
officially titled how I met your father
was back on even more encouraging was
that the project had fallen into the
hands of Isaac app taker and Elizabeth
Berger two members of the writing team
behind the NBC drama D this is us
however as this is us became a bonafide
hit both app taker and Bircher found
themselves unable to proceed with How I
Met Your father
Fox chairman Dana Walton told deadline
in August 2017 that the studio would be
trying to develop the spin-off with
different writers adding that they would
be starting from scratch and not using
any elements of the previous How I Met
Your dad whatever comes of the spin-off
one thing's for sure it has to be a
legend wait for it dary
legendary
[Music]